[Music]
you have five kids five kids that's
unusual in Los Angeles yes one wife
[Laughter]
that's just one wife and five kids so
far do your kids think you're funny uh
sometimes and sometimes it's
exasperatingly exhausting I mean you
know be nice to Conan tonight yeah yes
and you know it's it's tough sometimes
they do sometimes they don't I like to
hit them when they're mad at me which I
don't you you try to be funny
yeah like what do you do I'll sometimes
do a character right you know they're
mad so you walk in the bedroom hey
what's going on old man getting getting
down on you is that right you know I'd
do it follows you I just run away hey
what y'all to do is get you a stick and
make a bindle out of it you know the
bindle is an old hobo bindle you just
get yourself a red handkerchief put all
of your worldly possessions in that
handkerchief tied to that stick and the
loan you go to the rail yard you do that
to an angry 11 year old girl and she's
gonna kick you either they're helpless
yeah they're cutting yeah they'll try to
be angry with that they can't yeah
because I'm not the same guy
they might commiserate they might tell
that guy how much they hate dad
yep the old creepy hobo I can't honestly
tell me what your dad like yes they're
defenseless Conan let me come over and
sit for your day when they're okay keep
that guy away from my kids
but I'll hold him close to you Conan
Conan wait say we go to your house
tonight no just take a nice bath no you
and I in a bath yeah me you boys I would
pay a lot of money to see the four of us
and that can't the three of us in this
character in a bath together hey Conan
yeah it might cost less than you think
what's up on anchorman two ones free
folder I try to get away from this guy
now you get them focused hey but you got
to look at my eyes the whole time you
folks are the ones that are making it
dirty anchorman to the fans the do they
go crazy go crazy for you guys and there
was even a fan recently I saw a chant I
was online a champ tattoo a tattoo of
your character did you see this yet look
at this who's the guy on the double chin
what's going on Wow it's there's gotta
be I mean that's that's someone taking
an incredible commitment for the rest of
their life right and what's he saying
really like that's my guy is that was
already saying that's who I am that's so
enamored of like yep that's me that
champ kind of course being a misogynist
racist terrible alcoholic a jingoist a
homophobe and a latent homosexual so
that's that too is quite a declaration
he wants to say something yeah you have
a you have another film yeah I'm an out
soon called it's called cheap thrills
cheap thrills yeah it's a it's a
pressure cooker it's it's a sinister
dark thriller with comedic undertones
Wow yeah you describe that like a chef
describing a what a complicated dish
here's why it was an independent film we
shot in 14 days here in Los Angeles and
the whole time I thought wow this is
really its sinister it's dark and I saw
it with a festival audience and they're
laughing and I couldn't and but I don't
know how to describe it because if you
describe it as a dark comedic thriller
they'll think it's a comedy but you say
well it's a sinister thriller with
comedic undertones like you know you
said something you might see described
on a menu or the info button of your
television show nice tied together with
that comedy bit Thanks let's all get in
that hot tub together